Naruto needs no introduction The
Adventures of everyone's favorite
jumpsuit wearing ninja rocked the anime
world in pretty much a decade of
dominance in the 2000s and just when we
thought it was all over turns out it
wasn't it didn't take long for a sequel
boruto to start storming the seed but
we'll leave that for another time for
now please enjoyed this showcase of
Naruto's plethora of epic and dramatic
moments moments which would surely show
anyone why the series has become one of
the great legends and pioneers in the
world of Shonen anime
[Music]
at number 10 we'll start off with the
battle between Gaara and Rock Lee many
people lauded the Chunin exams Ark as
one of the best arcs in early Naruto and
if you have to pick one fight in the
whole tournament I'd go for this one
every time
who knew that gutsy Rock Lee would be
the one to take Gaara to the limit trust
me even if we're all savvy viewers who
knew that Gaara would come out on top
the fight still kept all the fans at the
edge of their seats throughout the fight
there's a lingering sense that Rock Lee
might just pull off the upset from
matching Gaara speed to releasing
never-seen-before power Rock Lee's
tenacity seemed unstoppable in a way
part of the young 14 year old me wish
they pulled the trigger on this one
[Music]
[Applause]
next up we have Naruto's return in Sage
Mode and his battle against pain Cano ha
and its champions have all been
devastated at the face of the sheer
might of pain and as all hope seems lost
who else deserves to make his grand
entrance but our hero it's a moment
capped off by a hero's welcome for our
protagonist after all these years
Naruto's finally acknowledged as the
triumphant hero that he's become he's
come a long way on the hero's journey
and after all the ridicule and heartache
Naruto finally gets the recognition he
deserves from everyone
Oh
[Music]
next in line is the scene where Naruto
finally accepts the nine tails sealed
within him let's just say for the most
of the series Naruto's relationship with
Kurama has been rocky to say the least
the moment the two decide to put their
differences aside in the fourth shinobi
world war and work together is a moment
that would send chills down any fan
spine it's a necessary step forward in
the hero's journey and the scene of the
Shonan hero finally coming to terms with
the powers that he's shunned for so long
is truly a sight to behold it looks
great when it happened in Bleach and it
certainly looks awesome as hell in this
series
[Music]
like everything's okay
[Music]
Cochran or little convener
what you do is huge here bring goods the
next entry on the list is the third
hokages sacrifice during invasion of
Konoha Naruto's a series full of
heartache and death and one of the very
first instances of this is when the
Third Hokage
sarutobi dies in the climax of the Kanoa
crush arc in an effort to stop the
deceptive and powerful Orochimaru
sarutobi invokes the Shinigami realizing
that he still has no power to defeat the
evil shinobi for good
sarutobi decides on the next best course
of action sealing the evil shinobi
through the arms and preventing him from
using ninjutsu at the cost of invoking
the Shinigami however sarutobi has to
pay with his very own life so Tobias
death marks one of the first major
losses that Naruto fans had to
experience orochimaru's invasion has
been repelled by the cost of the
villages biggest cornerstone
[Music]
host up next we have the reveal of
Toby's true identity ever since his
introduction the Toby character has been
an enigma constantly shifting from
comedy relief to credible threat on a
whim a few would have expected the mask
Toby to be one of the last Akatsuki
members left standing turns out that
Toby's actually obito uchiha who
proceeds to further add fuel to the fire
of the fourth shinobi world war his
subsequent battles with the heroes
culminating with him taking control of
the ten tails are some of my favourite
fights in the final arc it also helps
that he gets some redemption towards the
end making a nice personal parallel to
Naruto
[Music]
[Applause]
next up we have guy opening the eight
gate to take on mother er but most of
the series fans have seen Mike guy as
the epitome of that one strong yet
quirky character while we know of him as
a master of the eight gates technique
guy mostly spent most of the series as a
goofy mentor figure for our heroes it
would take until the latter parts of the
story before we witness what he's really
capable of forget him being capable of
defeating kisame which is a feat that's
impressive in its own right Martha one
of the most powerful ninjas in the world
is made to respect guys strength after
receiving a dose of the full power of
the eight gates this is the first time
we ever see all eight gates being
released in battle and boy is it a
spectacle while it didn't do the trick
in ending mother earth not that anything
worked anyway seeing the pinnacle of the
techniques a sight to behold
[Applause]
next on the list is Itachi's battle
against Sasuke and the revelation of the
truth behind the Uchiha clan Massacre
one of the main driving forces behind
Sasuke's action in much of the series
revolved around getting stronger
for what purpose revenge against his
brother Itachi who murdered the entire
Uchiha clan leaving him as the only
survivor it would only be proper for the
brothers to have their fated showdown
and they delivered unleashing their
amazing techniques on one another it's
Sasuke who eventually came out on top
as if the emotional farewell between the
brothers isn't enough it's revealed that
Itachi had massacred the Uchiha clan in
order to prevent a coop deer tap which
would have led to a civil war the reveal
that Itachi had been a hero all along
was one twist that shook the very
foundations of the series
next we have moderate appearance in the
fourth shinobi war what an entrance
one deserved by no less than what many
consider to be the series real final
boss after being restored thanks to the
arrow tense a mother er lives up to all
the hype as he crashes into the
battlefield devastating the fourth
division in his wake we can see in that
very scene how far ahead he is and how
he effortlessly defeats an entire army
with his intelligence and prowess not
only that he proceeds to single-handedly
defeat the car gaze the tailed beasts
and pretty much everything thrown at him
miracle after miracle wouldn't be enough
to stop him from casting the infinite
tsukuyomi that engulfs the world it
would require some good old plot
convenience to finally put him down for
good yes kono mo know what I see what I
see this episode honest he'll say no
kousaka's no densetsu Nina's right there
merica number twos certainly one of the
most iconic losses for fans of the
series Jiraiya's death for the longest
time the pervy and ever lovable member
of the legendary sannin has been the
closest person to a father figure for
Naruto knowing this it kind of felt
inevitable that he would fall somewhere
down the line this just happens in his
mission to gather Intel he goes down in
a blaze of glory putting up one hell of
a fight against Conan and the numerous
panes before finally going down despite
lamenting over his failures as he faces
his end Jiraiya's death doesn't turn out
to be entirely gloom and doom make no
mistake this is one of the saddest
moments in the series however seeing
Jiraiya die with the smiles also one of
the most uplifting moments in the entire
series the Masters part in the story has
ended with his death but he knows for
world that he can leave the rest to his
young pupil to save the world
[Music]
call it it's Tom washing he not took on
all and finally the number one in the
list is the final battle between Naruto
and Sasuke
of course the series just had to end
this way it's as destined that the final
battle of the series would be a
no-holds-barred battle between the hero
and his rival Naruto and Sasuke are no
strangers to fighting each other but
this is the battle that culminates all
the build-up that's been set up since
early on in the series more than just a
battle of strength this is the ultimate
battle of philosophies that the series
take so much pride in if talk no Jitsu
is any indication
Sasuke can be seen as the culmination of
all the ideologies that Naruto had to
overcome in his journey and no one else
could be a more fitting final opponent
for our hero not murderer not Obito and
certainly not Kaguya the fact that the
final battle ended in a technical draw
with Naruto only winning over his
longtime rival through his ideology and
not his strength cements this as one of
the top moments in the series
Naruto's a series full of many more epic
touching and straight-up heartbreaking
moments I'm a hundred percent sure that
a top ten list wouldn't cover everything
in the series is decorated rum I hope to
hear from you in the comments section on
what moments you think should have been
included in the list and which is your
personal favorite leave a like if you
enjoyed this video and subscribe if you
haven't already for more anime content
I'll see you next time on vinnie tube
[Music]